he is Ernie Johnson back here on the
show how are you Ernie whoops I'm
outstanding man welcome from San Antonio
it's been a wonderful wonderful weekend
here man really really cool and and
thanks for the kind words on the
partnership - we've had a great time
with CBS finishing up our eighth year
man and so there'll be fun tonight man I
know you're gonna be watching oh my gosh
I'm gonna have my chair pulled up so in
terms of the coverage between Turner and
CBS does Raftery send the receipt for
his new glasses to CBS or to David Lee
via Turner who who does he send that to
that's gonna be coming our way because
the game was on TBS and so I would
that's how it work I would say no I I'm
not a legal mind by any means but that's
that's where I said I would say where
were you working mr. Wrather ey was on
TBS that night Monday mister lady
throwing on the Walgreens and pick up
some more reading yeah I like it
man that was uh that was an incredible
Villanova performance the other night
are earning so walk me through what you
think needs to be done against Villanova
by Michigan tonight best you can tell
here well well which I'm glad you asked
because I do have a theory a working
theory here which I will again be
espousing on our to our pregame show
beginning at 7:00 o'clock Eastern Time
on TV oh nice thank you and so here it
is since we are in Texas San Antonio
both of these teams I think I think the
best case scenario for Michigan is this
they have to play tonight like they
played against Texas A&M and hope that
Villanova place like they did against
Texas Tech because in those games
I mean Michigan was all over in in and
shot the three ball well 62% for the
game never trailed in the game minta and
Villanova against Texas Tech went for
424 from three
they shot 33% still won that game
obviously won it by 12 but I think
that's kind of what it's going to take I
think Michigan is going to have to play
I'm not going to say it first the game
but they got to be really really good
tonight and they've got to just
defensively they get after you and so I
think if they can if they can really
limit Villanova's threes then you got a
chance and here's the magic number is 18
because as you played in that clip 18 3
is made by going over in their last game
record but you know how many threes
Michigan is allowed in the tournament
get out of here
eight kids Michigan is allowed 18 threes
in the tournament Villanova had that
many in the game the other night so
that's just a little something for you
rich thank you for letting me about my
gosh you're you're you're a [ __ ] full of
idiots Ernie Johnson chock full of
nuggets you are you are ready you are
ready for tonight and in terms of your
hosting role for that what's the best
story you've heard what do you thinks
the best story or a feature or anything
of tonight's game with any of the
players coaching staffs schools what
have you Ernie well I mean I you know I
think we're gonna have a feature tonight
on the the Raleigh massimino influence
on Villanova and his influence on Jay
right go back to 85 and that incredible
shooting night that Nova had when they
won the championships in and so I don't
know if there's any particular story but
I just think I think they're all good
and I and I think when I think about
stories and the whole tournament you
know you just from UMBC and and Loyola
Chicago and that's great run they had I
mean that's what it's like every year
when you when you do this and you
suddenly you're talking about players
that you really didn't know much about
before the tournament started and and
and that's what that's what makes it
great and and so we hope to put a
finishing touch on this one as we did
two years ago when we had it for the
first time you know in the game that
came down to the ball
all in the air as horn goes off and then
the celebration begins so let's hope we
have something rivaling what we had two
years ago and in terms of that Rollie
Massimino J right that's interesting I
look forward to that feature tonight as
part of your pregame coverage 7:00
eastern time on TBS that is that you
know Jay Wright doesn't get mentioned
often with Coach K and with Roy Williams
we had Coach K versus Jim Boeheim in the
in the mix in this tournament the
so-called Blue Bloods of NCAA Tournament
basketball do you think that tonight J
right
regardless win or lose enters that
Pantheon right now yeah sure certainly
and I think one of the things about Jay
and this is just what happens if you go
through a bunch of times where maybe
it's perceived as underachieving or not
being able to break through a ceiling
you know and only good enough to get
this far which kind of dogged him for a
little while and and it was yeah he does
that you know he's he hasn't had the
grades it says but he's this great
looking George Clooney kind of the guy
and he has the great suits and and then
you gotta kind of get lost in all that
kind of a facade and and and I think
he's shown that yeah he belongs in that
in that elite company of great coaches
in the country Ernie Johnson here on the
Rich Eisen show going into tonight's
game so it's gonna be you
we had Clark Kellogg on in the first
hour and you and Clark and Kenny and
Charles that the mixes evening on TV
that'll be the four of us and on a
separate separate set will be Greg
Gumbel and Seth Davis okay Jim Boeheim
you mentioned is going to join us in the
first segment grab and so we had him we
had him on we had Mike Brey on the other
day during our pregame festivities and
and and that was fun because because you
know what what happened with with me and
Mike different after the selection show
did you were you aware of this Miller
and he go for you here's what here's
what happened when we did the Select
show and we were revealing the 68 teams
in the field alphabetically it was my
turn and I and I said now here
alphabetically is where if Notre Dame's
in the field this is where they would
show up oh it's right in Ohio State
showed and then Ohio State showed up and
so I got home I got home that night and
I'm just you know doing some work in my
office and and and I look on the Twitter
and and here's a tweet from a
publication up in South Bend saying that
here was Mike brace quote after talking
about the disappointment of not making
the tournament he said and he said well
and and you know and I were watching the
selection show and here's Ernie Johnson
and he has this dramatic pause and then
we're not in and so next time I see
Ernie Johnson I'm gonna punch him in the
face oh boy so lo and behold the other
day my producer called so then Mike Mike
Brey is gonna join us in the first
segment I said why that's good if we're
gonna have to talk about this this punch
so so we did him we had a great time
with it cuz I had I reached out to him
that night on on text and I should have
it I didn't just do a job you're doing
your job you're setting Steen's you're
secure creating drama you're doing what
yes I said there was no no it'll will or
anything on my part and he texted me the
next morning I would say hey obviously I
was I was joking mostly and so it was
mostly fun and I liked it
he's great he's Mike raised great and
and it was it was very fun to have him
there are our guys in the paint box at a
at a a picture of Mike berry with boxing
gloves delivering a right cross to my
jaw and so I know it was also seeing
that's one of the things that makes you
so great Ernie is it's never about you
you know and that's why I you know
always enjoyed talking he try to aspire
to be more like you in my role I would
have said just anywhere but know anyone
long they said anywhere but the face
anywhere but the face this is my
moneymaker that's how I would have
responded you know it's why I don't play
pic that's why I don't play pick-up
basketball anymore because
by you know if I take an elbow to the
chops then in the next job you hear if
you hear from me OB go ahead pump three
you're ready well Ernie look forward to
tonight's coverage really do I've
enjoyed it immensely to this point and
just you know again if you're on the
postgame show and it's Villanova and J
rights they're just be gentle just know
that there's a bunch of us out there
that'll be Oh ask him a poll question
ask
Ernie's perfect for this poll question
here Brock you want to set
Ernie up our contest Jim Nantz will be
talking awarding the champion oh you're
on the post game you're on the post game
what I'm saying is you know for those of
us who are just you know junkies that
even after here's the poll question okay
Chris Brockman my on-air producer and
compadre and Mike del 2fo who is our
audio executive who barely pays
attention to the program we all put in
our our brackets and whoever loses must
wear a clown makeup for the entirety of
tomorrow's three-hour show unless unless
any of my children who have been in the
competition I had my nine seven and
four-year-old daughter
fill out a bracket this year if we lose
to any of them then all three of us
miracle must wear clown makeup
and if my seven-year-old did what I did
not do which is choose Michigan to win
it all because I just didn't want to
jinx them so if Michigan wins then I
must wear clown makeup throughout
tomorrow's show with my other compadres
ask him the poll question Chris yeah
Ernie what should Rich be rooting for
tonight a Michigan win or to not wear
clown makeup tomorrow or any I look to
you for advice this should be rooting
for Michigan went okay there you go
and Ernie joins the 83% also say that
but clown makeup Ernie
I mean $40 you know it that's kind of
it's kind of you know it's it's icky you
know I just and I don't you know I've
got one of those clown things too you
know
are you compound fears and I'm one of
those clowns hearing kind of you know I
can look at it for a couple of seconds
and it's like hey stop okay so no but
but I think okay I think you can't you
can't help but root for your for your
album all I'm let's go into it earning
the dude thanks brother always
appreciate how by the way yes in my in
my bracket by the way heist I still like
Michigan State over Arizona good thing
you're not in our competition cuz my
four-year-old would be beating you right
now Ernie that's my wife and my oldest
son are both beating me and my amazing
in sorts me a long year have a great
time then I will be watching rich thanks
Matt great talk that you got as always
at Turner Sports CJ on Twitter the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience